[Music]
time now
for the press preview a first look at
the front pages as they arrive
over the remainder of the hour we'll be
taking a look at what's making the
headlines with the journalist and author
christina patterson
and the pr consultant alex dean to those
two in just a second
but let's take a look through the stack
um starting with this
covert infections surge the lead in the
times
after a 76 rise in a week but it seems
that
still not yet enough to stop the june
21st plan to finally
end lockdown and the telegraph though
reporting that the vaccine rollout may
also be
speeded up to help with the process at
the time between first and second jabs
could be reduced from 12
to 8 weeks here's the sun
it says the prime minister was urged
last week to stick to ending lockdown on
june 21st now the daily express quotes
the health secretary as saying
the britain's vaccine rollout is helping
win the battle
against new variants now here's the
daily mail
it leads with that item we just had a
second ago the ruling that the fires are
vaccine is
safe for children aged 12 to 15 saying a
roll
out for teenagers is but weeks away
a related story in the guardian which
reports that school leaders are calling
for pupils to be vaccinated as a matter
of priority what a border farce
exclamation mark that's the lead in the
mail after it discovered that channel
migrants have been secretly picked up by
british boats
while still in french waters and taken
to dover
and the financial times leads with plans
for major reform of the tax system by
g7 economies to make sure that
multinational companies
pay some more and the daily star reports
on bbc one's plan to hire continuity
announcers with
regional accents and an effort to be
more diverse
we're joined tonight by the journalist
and author christina patterson and the
pr consultant
alex dean lovely to see you both um and
a lot an awful lot in the papers
uh this evening christina on covey let's
start with
the front page of the times from a
distance this does look worrying their
headline covert infection
surge the fastest rise since september i
mean how concerned are you by this we
always have to remember dopely that
there was always going to be a rise in
covert infections when we started
uh getting rid of the restrictions
yes there was always going to be a rise
in coveted infections but 76
i would say is very worrying indeed and
there wasn't always going to be a rise
on this scale the reason it's on this
scale
is because a prime minister didn't close
flights from india for more than two
weeks
even after they knew they they knew
there was a variant of concern from
india in early april and it took i think
two and a half maybe three weeks before
they actually made india a red country
so as a result of that we now have the
indian now called delta variant
spreading like billio
and uh it's very very worrying and and
not least since it's
so incredibly infectious in schools i
mean
they don't yet know how much more
infectious it is but neil ferguson who's
been
a key voice through this whole thing
thinks it could be as much as a hundred
percent more
infectious let's hope it's not as high
as that but they seem to think it's
probably 60 to 70
more infectious which is very much more
infectious
so although we don't yet know whether
this will have a huge impact on
hospitalizations and deaths
if you open everything up it's likely to
and the other issue that i'm really
worried about is long covered
we know today that was reported that a
million people
are suffering long covered and i think
about 400 of those have had it for more
than a year
in the last couple of days i've spoken
to several people who either have it or
who have children you have
it today i spoke to someone whose 21
year old daughter
can't has a horrible smell all the time
can't taste anything and this is nine
months on
so i think you know let's just give it a
few more weeks
and uh and get everybody get more people
doubly vaccinated and then the
youngsters won't have to pay the price
in long covered
alex are you minded uh for for a few
more weeks of the conditions that we're
all under or you have the opinion that
you know look
plenty of people have been getting
vaccinated the vaccination program is
going well
why not relax on the 21st
the latter and the reason that my view
is the latter is that
the rise in cases which we are seeing
and is undeniable
seems now to be uncoupled from um
hospitalization
and that's happening because vaccine
program is working
and unless we're going to say that we're
not going to unlock until we've got no
coded left in which case we might as
well give up
there's going to come a point at which
we say as a country
we know that there is going to be some
kobe we're going to have to live with it
but with the most important thing and
this is the big public health message
isn't to stay locked down it's to get
vaccinated as soon as possible and on
that the government is absolutely
right but i must say you know sage
produced
five kind of outcome predictions when we
produced this roadmap and of all five of
them
the most optimistic had us still with a
hospitalization rate
double where we are now we are doing
twice as well
as sage thought we would do on their
most optimistic prediction
so on that basis there's no reason not
to unlock on time
christina though the the the story in
the front of the ft weekend edition
you know whitehall is is clearly looking
at this
there's been enough briefing in the
papers to suggest that this is
a course of action that's at very least
under under active consideration
if a decision hasn't already been taken
yes well i think boris johnson will be
very very reluctant
to delay not least because of pressure
from tory back benches and indeed people
like
alex who are you know very vocal within
the tory party
or at least affiliated to the tory party
but i do think
i think there are reasons for concern i
don't just mean you know from the point
of view i just mentioned but i mean
even for someone like boris johnson who
as we know from dominic cummings
testimony last week
wanted to be the mayor of george the
mayor in jaws throughout this whole
thing and as far as i can tell he's done
a very good job at that impersonation
i think um the maths is very frightening
on this
and even if you completely ignore the
plight of youngsters who
if they'd only held on a few more weeks
wouldn't get long covered who will get
it if we open up
i think the mess doesn't look great and
so if white water making plans knowing
the political pressures to unlock on the
21st of june then i think
politicians must be pretty alarmed
including the prime minister
hang on that's not quite right
civil servants should prepare for
different potential outcomes that's
their job
it's when civil servants don't prepare
for example for
the other side of a binary referendum if
you don't want a particular outcome to
come about
that's when things go wrong and as for
the kind of name checking it's
kind of extraordinary how people get
recreated isn't it last year dominic
cummings was the devil of barnard castle
and you wouldn't believe the word he
said now he's the
he's the oracle of truth because he's
bashing the prime minister
both the transport secretary and the
health secretary have also raised
concerns about delta
yeah of course of course it's right to
have concerns and my was responding to
the point that it's right the civil
servants prepare but everything that
we've seen so far points to the
predictions on roadmap being correct as
they are now
following the science and so forth and
that's why the prime minister had this
long wait to the 21st of june we've been
waiting three weeks after three weeks
after three weeks
but please do let me finish my my point
which was that neil ferguson
was someone who gave us a set of rules
he couldn't keep himself so it's kind of
amusing to find him rehabilitated he's
like the economist who predicted nine of
the last one recessions
uh christina but let's both talk about
the story in the uh on the story in the
daily telegraph
that the idea that they're going to
frankly it's a story that's been
reported a few times already second jabs
are going to be sped up in an effort to
lift restrictions
but there is a lag factor with the
second with the second vaccination
we've been told you've got to wait two
three weeks perhaps to get the full
efficacy of it so so what exactly is
going on here then christina in your
mind
well i think i think that they are just
trying to do what they can to get as
much of the population vaccinated
as quickly as possible and they already
brought forward the second vaccine for
the over 50s and from 12 weeks to 8
weeks and the plan is to do the same for
the over 40s um and i think
look you know i'm not i'm not i feel
like an epidemiologist after the last uh
16 months but clearly i'm not and the
that's for
you know the uh joint vaccines committee
to decide but
i it seems to make it it makes sense to
to do that i mean the only thing
you would you know one could say is that
the second
uh vaccine for the second dose of astro
zenica
is meant to be more effective after 12
weeks and after eight weeks but that
seems to be
a kind of nicety we can't really be uh
worrying about at the moment so it it
seems to make sense to
to bring forward uh second vaccines as
soon as they can do that
i mean now excuse me sorry alex
it was it was a point where we made it
during the papers last night
when you have an incredibly effective
second jab
vaccination program it does make it a
lot more difficult for the prime
minister
to be go slow to to move away from the
june 21st date doesn't it because
as i think you were saying just at the
very beginning of the program look if
people have got two jabs in their arm
they will be sitting there going look
what else do i have to do
before i get to get my life yes i mean
it's rather
it's dark now we're starting to talk
about treating vaccinated people in the
same way that we treat unvaccinated
people
the point of having the vaccination is
to be free once again and the
ramifications
of having the jab should be profound for
you unless
lest my remarks suggest i'm some sort of
form of skeptic i've had my first jab
astrazeneca and i i'm very keen to have
my second i think that the acceleration
government should do
is bringing forward jabs and getting
second jabs into our arms as soon as
possible
but it seems to me on all the evidence
that the 21st of june deadline
is one that we can absolutely honor guys
we will pause there
and we'll have plenty more to talk about
after the break including this are
uk border patrols actually collecting
channel migrants in french waters
there's the story there we'll be
discussing the daily mail front
after this
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview
christina and alex still here with their
selection of the stories
and analysis this isn't this is an
interesting one in the daily mail and i
just did a a quick set a quick request
to my floor manager to see if i could
get a copy of the
the inside on this story because i don't
quite understand it
what a border farce what on earth is
going on with this
yeah it would seem that not only do we
now have a situation where
our arrangements effectively invite
people to undertake a very dangerous
journey across a hazardous body of water
one of the
busiest in the world to come as illegal
migrants which is what you are if you're
trying to come
in this fashion rather than applying for
asylum or refugee status
where you should do instead of just
doing that
what we're also doing is running a taxi
service
into french waters to pick people up and
bring them back here
to be absolutely clear if somebody is
still in french waters
there are the french polices and the
french authorities responsibility
and if the french have got hold of them
they should be taking them back to
france and dealing with them there
indeed that's what the french should be
doing with all of these people
quite what it is that's so unattractive
about france that means they don't apply
for asylum there in the first place
i don't know but let's be clear this is
down to the french and it's
extraordinary that we're running this
taxi service to go and pick them up and
i and only
the mind boggles at the extent to which
this will encourage more people to try
to do exactly what is happening here
christina you you'll forgive me for
having a slight sense of disconnect here
because you know this is the home office
of you know the hostile environment
policy
pretty patel is is is not necessarily
known for
for trying to send boats out there so i
i do wonder if we're getting the full
story on all of this but as alex says
if these people these boats are in
french waters surely the immediate
responsibility
if lives are at risk is on the french
well it's an absolutely baffling story
and without more information it's quite
hard to comment on it i mean my only
uh sort of wicked thought is perhaps
they're doing it to
upset pretty patel because obviously she
has such a very hard
policy but um
that's machiavellian it's
absolutely baffling i can't i mean you
know look if people were
struggling for their lives in front of
you or you know they had fallen off a
flimsy boat then
i would challenge anyone not to want to
scoop them up and rescue them
whatever the rights and wrongs of their
legality or illegality and alex is right
these are
mostly i mean you know of course until
people claim asylum
and uh if they claim asylum and are
found to be eligible
or not we don't know but the the method
of getting into the country is
not legal and they are mostly in the
hands of people smugglers so
um at the moment we have a completely
broken system where we are
delegating who gets into our country
into the hands of people who are
operating illegally and who are making
money out of it and people are drowning
in the process so
i i think that the whole system hugely
needs overhauling but
it does seem surreal for our border
force to be going into french waters and
saying come on over
well in part in part three of the story
in fact we discovered that it was a home
office source uh
for this story we know that ms patel has
not always enjoyed the best of
relationships with her workforce there
christine i take us though inside the
times last story you get 20 seconds for
this
the headline drink drive through
this is good well um
a female soldier um keeley
goodall who is um a lance corporal
was found to be three times over the
drink drink drive limit but she uh the
officer who stopped her she tried to
order a mcdonald's from thinking she was
in a drive-through
and i'm afraid this pic of me i mean i
suspect many of us have been drinking
slightly more than we should have done
during lockdown
on the other hand having been locked
down we haven't been stopped for our
drink and driving because that's been
even more illegal
so i'm certainly officer would be a bit
a bit torn if we were in a car beyond
five miles from where we should be
and also over the limit but anyway let's
wrap this up before alex spontaneously
combusts
on the right there we will see you again
at the top of the 11 o'clock car for
much much more